hi I'm Craig Howard from Lucifer games
I'm here to show you a quick overview of
geometry wars dimensions so show me
taller I mentioned it's got several new
modes we've got a single-player
adventure mode we've got a classic mode
which shows you all of the has all the
existing modes from drama tours retro
evolved to we have bonus levels we're
for the first time ever an online
competitive multiplayer and we also have
a local co-op multiplayer for up to four
days I'm going to show you the adventure
mode so this is where you've got over 50
levels that can be unlocked and open
within the game all of them provide a
unique challenge and gameplay objective
we've all got their own leaderboards so
it's going to show you a few of the
different types of levels in the game so
we're going to start off with one of the
more conventional shooting star levels
but one of the other new features we
have in the game is drones but they've
all got different drones of different
abilities so okay so we've got a ram
drone it goes off and hits the enemies
they have a sniper drone selectively
shoots at enemies at a nearby a defender
drone that sort of covers where you're
going to shoot attack drone it also sort
of shoots in the direction you're going
as you can see here we've changed the
grits then out 3d this one's got a
slight twist in it so you can see the
enemies in all corners of the map so
this game's running a 1080p on all
next-gen platforms at 60 frames per
second
it was really using sort of the power of
the new hardware and sure we keep the
smooth frame rate and what's doing all
the post effects for the render
see I've just done lots of power up as
well these are moves that John tools so
if I mentions a different enemies appear
different formations when you destroy
them got many of the classic enemies
from the previous games we do have new
ones that can discover you should play
in a game so we call this game very
dimensions because now with the grid we
have full 3d grits
I'm sure you want now so these really
exciting because it gives the new
possibilities with different sort of
attacks and ways we can create level to
different players different tactics when
you're playing the game so on this one
I'm going to use the attack drone but
I'm also going to use a a new thing
called special something use a home and
special which is also on the other
trigger so I've got a smartphone at home
in my files as you can see for this grid
is in full 3d so I can get to the
endpoint security after fly down it
gives you a difference always to sort of
view the action different ways to attack
the enemy's bullets just keep continuing
all the way around the grid so you can
sort of chase enemies even out out of
you and start destroying them
here with a massive swarm of enemies
coming from both sides so you also have
to avoid these new guys the rock so a
new enemy they change the shape of the
grid
they took walk around they always have
to apply a different path so she should
being chased or chasing the enemies no
instructable to your fire so you should
see in the shape one of the new new
features we advizr the grid creates
walls that come out of the grid and they
when they're red they're deadly when
they're blue they're not deadly but this
allows us to do certain things with the
dynamics and the grid where but this
level feels very much like you're
playing a scrolling style shooter
because the wards are always moving and
you have to compensate for that as
you're battling the enemies one of the
big things we've reporting are the
power-ups with the super state enemies a
lot of people weren't too keen that we
took them out of critter evolved too for
bringing those in it has been nice to
get these short bursts of sort of new
powers as you play the game the big
thing really for us was was bringing
more variety into the games we the other
game had such strong game modes had kind
of like five or six strong game modes
but we saw there's lots of possibilities
where we could go with that so if this
game was coming up 15 of those plus
we've got the classic modes as well so
we're really excited about that each
chapter of the game is you have a boss
battle at the end of each each chapter
and these are also new to the bosses are
very interesting because they create
their own enemy spawns and attacks so
you have a time limit to take out the
boss each stage of the boss
the skill player can try to kill enemies
and keep the boss alive as long as
possible to cease preparing his own
enemy waves and spawns we decided superb
bosses into the game as the fans were
really keen on us and tried to bring
them into the game but we were really
cautious that we wouldn't break the flow
of what makes the jongseo's game so what
we found is why having these these
bosses influence the level and create
their own enemy spawns it felt like it
was true to Jon tours it also gave the
drama and sort of action that you want
whenever possible and there's a lot of
ways to score big in these in these
levels as well hoo-wee real risk reward
mechanic each and each of the bosses are
all built around the concept that they
were there affecting the grid in a
negative way so the more he gets to the
game more sort of saw almost like a
disease that havoc weakened the grid
before and create different types of
enemies have in the game so it's just
seeing some of the features and some of
the new game ocean sharm tools
dimensions the game's packed full loads
of new things and stuff it's only a
little bit of content within it that
games out soon it's out on November 25th
on PlayStation 3 ps4 and steam and it's
out on the next day on Xbox one
succeed hope you're gonna like it thanks
a lot
you